dr martin luther king in 1963 obviously
you know had a speech
my dream would be similar to that i have
a dream
my dream for 2022 is equality and equal
rights for all for every american to
have easy access to the voting ballot my
dream for 2022 is to build on police
reform civilians and police in this
country about a very recent struggle
that has not been great for anybody in
this country i'm hoping you can come
together put our differences aside and
create a better future for our kids and
our family dr king once said life's most
persistent and urgent question is what
are you doing for others and here in
memphis that's i mean that's all we're
about here it's more than basketball
it's about giving back to the community
my dream for 2022 is to see more people
spread love and positivity i just want
to find a level of civility give back to
the core
where people are more compassionate more
caring my dream for 2022 is for
everybody to love themselves and love
others spread love my dream for 2022 is
to continue to fight for equal rights
for every marginalized group in this
country for the state of georgia and a
lot of other states to just implement
common sense voting laws and give more
opportunity for citizens to cast their
votes my dream for 2022 is you know for
eternal peace love and happiness for
myself and my family and continue to
thrive and be the best black male that i
can be people you know pay for for all
races everybody to be able to be
themselves now in public no matter what
that will be my dream for 2022
you